[موسيقى]
هي لا تتعلق بعمر بل هي عمليه تراكميه
وليست عمليه راديكاليه سريعه بتعبير
السياسيين تاتيك هكذا ولا بالمناسبه لا
احتفل باي تغيير سريع انا احتفل كثيرا
بالتغيير المتدرج ادعى للرسوخ المرحله
الملكيه هي مرحله جميله خالد اخي خالد
العمر قصير وليس همه بروفه في هذه الحياه
فيجب ان تجتهد في ان تحيا ولا ان تعيش
اجمل ما امكنك ما امكنك والحياه وتعتمد
على جودتها افكارك ولا تعتمد من الاحوال
على جوده ظروفك وان نعطيها قليلا بس قليل
من الاهميه لكن جوده الافكار هي هي هي
اللي تعطي الانسان
[موسيقى]
ذلك المرحله الملكيه تحتاج اليك ان تعمل
العقل هذا اولا امرا اخر في غايه الاهميه
العمر قصير هل ستخضع لمساله التجربه
والخطا لا طبعا لذلك قضيه الاحتكاك
بالعقلاء والناضجين والحكماء والقراءه
والاطلاع لا شك انه يعجل بالوصول الى هذه
المرحله من اخر الاشياء التي توصلت اليها
في هذه المرحله
من 60% 60 70% اخذوا ما تيسر منهم 30 عام
وهذا ايضا ينطبق على نفسي لا اطالب نفسي
بان اعطي بنسبه 100% ابدا ولا طالب 60 70%
من احد مظاهر المرحله الملكيه ايضا في
المرحله الملكيه بالمناسبه خلصت منهم
السيطره انا كان جتني مرحله معينه كنت
اعتقد ان المسؤول عن كل شيء عن تغيير
الاخرين عن تغيير الطباعهم عن بعض الاشياء
التي تزعجني لا لا لا لا لا الان وصلت الى
مرحله فيها اعتقد يعني احسب فيها شيئا من
النظري انني بدات اميز او بدات يعني اعرف
دائره مسؤولياتين
[موسيقى]